foreign
hello hello
welcome welcome
foreign
s lead to hogsmeade
hello hello
how's everyone doing
he fights a tree he Bubba as you know
Shadow Joe congrats
Omni hello
Aaron
Mr Barney sticks thank you thank you
hello Ness hello Emirates
hey democles
how's everyone doing
his voice
like coup gaurav
thank you Zeno
yeah it's just my voice
22 percent of you have beaten the game
already
by my
this game is massive
it is
your poaching days are over
thank you thank you
I love the game so far it's great I mean
it's massive so I don't really know
where to start I'm all over the place
but I love it
um yeah guys I'm gonna do some Hogwarts
Legacy videos I've got one
um wait what's coming out tomorrow
no tomorrow morning or sorry tomorrow at
uh 3 P.M eastern time I'm releasing the
history of Avada Kedavra
so kind of doing a deep dive with some
theories on who invented it
and then I've got a video coming out
which is talking about DLC
speculating
and then I'm gonna do some videos on
Ancient magic if the game is canon
um
yeah
stuff like that but if you have requests
then leave them in the comments
oh
love yourself
I mean there's there's lots of extended
lore out there
uh I've done a face reveal this is I
just don't really stream with my face
I'm in Slytherin yeah
does it make it does that make a big
difference if I stream with my face or
his voice enough
you know life the game nice
hell yeah
what's too dark
eat Schmidt you're gonna enjoy it
yeah I don't love
being on camera to be honest
and I'm so I'm just easing into
streaming so I thought I'd just do voice
get comfortable with the voice and then
maybe introduce video later on
that's better pleasure this should be an
achievement for petting old cats
whatever
yeah so the the DLC video that I've
actually already made it it's just not
coming out yet
um I discussed that aspect of the
tri-wizard tournament um because yeah it
would
interrupt Canon because
um
in Harry Potter it's 1994 that we see
the try wizard tournament and the one
before that is 1792 so there's a big gap
so if there was a try was a tournament
in this game it wouldn't make sense
Castle unfortunately must have been
quite stately in this time
unfortunately what's in this Castle
oh my
what was that some ancient Magic
Rebellion
um it got canceled after 1792.
um
I can't remember the name of the
creature what's the name of the creature
I've done a video on it uh
yeah cockatrice Broke Free and also lots
of students were dying
what's this in here
how do I get in this building
game is definitely worth it
get the game if you can
huh
Rebellion
experience
I'm in
hey wave time
a Nexus
oh
ex 21
oh interesting
you Blastoise
at dispatch oh
foreign
part of me wants to fly everywhere and
use flu powder and everything but then
the other part of me wants to just run
everywhere so I can see everything
these rocks have seen better days
Brian Rock has fooled you all to your
demise
yeah I think uh quidditch is probably
the most likely DLC because it wouldn't
contradict Canon and then now I also
think that potentially down the line
um other schools
because there isn't that much
information out there on the other
schools so be easy to introduce it
um
without sort of hindering their
creativity
here
rebellious
I'll try that with the broom
yeah I think they'll do online
no I don't sorry scratch that I don't
think so
um maybe a long time from now
but they have gone out of their way to
make a statement to say that they won't
do online so
few witches or Wizards correctly trace
the history of Scotland's indigenous
mazes back to their rightful Source the
15th century dark wizard known as Union
Blackwood born Union wood to a
non-magical branch of the Wood family
Union was misunderstood by his muggle
parents and in an effort to fit in
solace in the Family Trade hedge
trimming
he allegedly control the Black Thorn
bushes with his mind creating beautiful
designs with ease this both impressed
and infuriated his rather intolerant
family their resentment only worsened
upon young Union's invitation to
Hogwarts he was sorted into Southern
sorry into Hufflepuff house
okay I won't read it at all
what have we got here
it's like a place right out of a
storybook revelio
upper hogsfield is being terrorized by
ramrock's lawyer I couldn't help it over
here I did
nice to meet you my brother
and play it now
I'm unfortunately quite
much
live in fear okay let's get rid of these
it seems as though things are getting
worse loyalists must be oh my God
foreign
yeah I know it's just I don't even know
where to start I'm trying to do my
normal content
play the game
take notes but uh
for the first time in a long time
I didn't know where to start in terms of
what to cover
uh the new film with the old cast is not
happening that's just a rumor it's fake
news
all right
good for you
in the deepest fault
yeah the the cursed child is not
happening I'm down as a film
unfortunately
and it's not really Canon either
I think a lot of people would agree with
me on that
I think the best thing they could do is
make a TV show a prequel TV show
Marauders founders
uh Tom Riddle Origins
the Snape Origins Dumbledore Origins
that type of thing I think that'd be the
best case scenario what do you guys want
what would you want
prepared
I don't mind the cursed child it's not
my favorite I mean it
as far as all the games and films are
concerned it's it's my least favorite
hey true sighted
experience
your blood's on Round Rock's hands
both camps cleared Alan Beaumont will be
glad to hear that
revelio
foreign
if you guys could get a piece of DLC for
the game what would you what would you
want
top top Choice top three top three DLCs
go
I've got a video coming out next week on
the gaunt family which will include was
the history of the gaunt family and
Italy it will include ominous in it
seems Pleasant enough little place I do
miss the bustle of business hello good
news I was able to clear out Round
Rock's camps you cleared them out yeah
how
I want the trail was a tournament but
does contradict Canon so
and I think right now they've done a
really good job of of keeping everything
within the confines of Canon
I managed to catch them when my brother
you say Doha my fear for other ham
what do you have for sale
hey bulbasaurus Rex exactly thank you
sincerely
thank you for passing through
Rebellion hey Damian
yeah more morality
please
the game is Canon I think I mean I think
that's up to everyone's own
interpretation but it doesn't break
Canon at least
uh from what I can tell so far
so that's something
excuse me did you say something about
other schools I think would be amazing I
don't think we've met I'm Dorothy
sprottle I was just worrying about
Claire beaumont's brother bardov only
he's gone missing rumor is he was seen
in the forest practice often another
adventure
my player will be at her shop if you'd
like to speak with her
I'm like 10 finished the game
nothing
oh
maybe I'll do the main quest in a second
I wonder who lives here
proved dangerous if I'm not careful
oh looks like I'm stuck okay there we go
let's go off to the side here have a
look
back here
oh interesting
love yourself
my first time seeing Lee and fairy
I Kev hi El Camino
nice one Ben
yeah I mean Weasley gaunt Rookwood is
another one
um Victor Brookwood is related to
Augustus Rookwood the
um Death Eater and the Unspeakable
tell you this is
Ikea
yeah the rookwoods black
yeah I mean
they knocked it out of the park with
this game
check up
that was a bit too much hey scar Max
not sure how I'd fare in a little place
like this
foreign
what's the question scar makes
oh level 17. my goodness
aside from the Battle of Hogwarts has
there been any other time that Hogwarts
has been under siege on the same scale
I don't
think so
not that I can think of off the top of
my head
can't imagine
why that would have happened another
time
I mean hogsmeade was attacked by goblins
so you know that's kind of in the same
same vein
I think I'm quite a low level for this
uh Darth Christian I would ask the chat
because
I don't know uh take your time enjoy
yourself
don't rush through it
people have beaten the game what tips do
you have for Darth Christian who's just
doing his first playthrough
yeah use rebellio a lot
let me answer
[Music]
yeah side quests enjoy it
I haven't allocated all of my talents
actually because I was afraid of
messing it up
here
whoops
looks intriguing
them
in Ferry are a little too easy to eat
that must be part of
yourself
incendio
been pretty good
nice
ouch
what have we got here a cell non gear
Professor snake in your Professor Snape
he might have
pet all cats it's good advice
turn off the map yeah
Rebellion
don't mind if I do golden trimmed School
robe
yeah I know you can change the
appearance I just I'm changing gear
constantly so I don't really see the
the need
foreign
every time I equip something
you know
tell me stuff
yeah exactly I'm just I'm just equipping
new stuff constantly
what are you trying to say about the way
my character looks guys
what are you implying Hmm this could
prove dangerous if I'm not careful
donkologist hat
look at this
oh
there it is
that's the ticket thank you mainor
love the game
where's that voice coming from
they know the lies
my goodness
ah
it's shameful what you've done to
helpless beasts
nah that doesn't break Canon it just
means maybe more acrobatulous ran around
back then
am I supposed to be in this area at
level 15 I feel like maybe I'm not
because a lot of level 20 enemies
should I go back to the school like is
this for later I don't want to do things
seems a pleasant enough little place
Warren Quidditch
uniform
yeah I'm not good with nintendio
yeah I'm gonna definitely use clips from
the game to support my videos moving
forward
uh where is Claire
Beaumont
stay home
I do hope my brother is all right
Madame Beaumont
I believe I have some news of your
brother
what do you know of my brother
I'm truly sorry
evil evil
bottles
oh I should investigate
okay I'm gonna go do the main quest I
guess I guess I don't know should I
I don't want to rush them
thanks Cal Drogo
hmm
what have we got here
maybe I should do should I do a giveaway
foreign
pretty good
Rebellion
what do I do with this
what do you do on this uh Merlin trial
oh is it one of those
whoops
incendium
[Music]
foreign
doesn't count
oh my goodness it's so easy to
jump off
it's okay to help
did I do it
probably not
oh
God
I think that was it yeah
nice
thank you thank you okay let's go to the
let's go to The Dark Tower
how many Merlin trials are there
over here
only
96.
it's nothing we're not alone we are not
ran Rock's loyalists around a dozen I
can see but could be more can't we
operate past them into the tower we
could but we've no idea what's in the
tower more importantly however I'd like
to know why they're here they've set up
camp just ahead I suggest we investigate
a little before doing anything else at
let's go
well this isn't ideal
no it isn't let the folds are similar to
uh Dementors except they eat flesh
and they live in the tropics
arrival main or
yeah the flesh
they're almost scarier than Dementors
oh I need that uh flu location
no no no no no spoilers
whoops
[Music]
foreign
uh yeah this was the stealth part but
yeah I had used accio
as he was using the charm so
there you go oh I didn't use Ancient
magic I always forget to use Ancient
Magic
directly from Round Rock
oh
boss
story
[Applause]
time
nothing this is different somehow
it's more than mere coincidence that we
encountered Round Rock's loyalists to
gold gold gold gold gold
it's nothing yeah
looks like we found the entrance
it's locked
okay
an unlocking John
um
how strong is our player character in
game
I mean I don't know I don't think we're
on that level maybe towards the end of
the game I'm not that far yet so I don't
know
I need to claim some challenges
foreign
welcome to San bakar's Tower
welcome hello professor
I did Professor I'm glad to see that I
was correct well I surmise based on the
commotion I heard we did not Professor
we the Goblins were aware of my fault is
disquieting enough but if they have also
made downstairs near the entry commanded
to access as Professor fig cannot join
remember what you
we're going to need to understand how
ran rocks look for the moment however
yes sir
that said be careful
useless fig
unbelievable
a reservoir of ancient magic downstairs
near the entry
Rebellion
that's nice of you skarmex
I've seen this before
Gringotts and the Restricted Section
is this uh tricky this trial
or is it
revelio
uh okay go down says
let's have a look around
okay
here we go
Scottish jumper attire
very nice
that's cool
all traces of ancient Magic
something must be different
hmm
what's happening here oh who's this he's
a never welcome sight
I just don't know what to expect this
time
let me open
too easy
these look for me
here
um I haven't used Stupify yet
at all actually
super Fire worth it
I just haven't even bothered to equip it
what should I replace
oh
foreign
gotcha
yeah I haven't uh been using it I guess
back here
changes when I move in and out of the
archway
foreign
okay
what do I do here do I go through
yeah the ancient Magic
feel
s cool
am I missing something
[Music]
but when I pass through the archway it's
blocked by a wall
go around the portal
oh like that
like this
go around it you mean
more statues aha
um
thank you
Rebellion
okay good to know
I presume I'm looking for traces of
ancient Magic
where
revelio
looks like uh ancient Magic
Pacquiao
oh this is it isn't it
wow
okey-dokey I know what to do
[Music]
see daisies
foreign
what is happening
hey Michael
uh you haven't missed much just doing
the
first trial
huh
IO
not very far
uh how do I do this one what did that
burst of magic change on both sides of
the archway
something must be different
oh do I have to go back through or is
this the right side to be on
right now
oh
it seems like ought to explore this
archery from both sides
okay and what what should I do now
open two suggestions I need to see how
the room changes when I move in and out
of the archway
uh
[Music]
I don't know
it needs to be on the other side of the
bridge
oh okay so what should I do
so that's it I need to use both sides of
the archway to get the platform to the
other side of the bridge
other way
oh I see
I see
so that's it I need to use both sides of
the archway together right the other
side of the bridge
everything in this chamber just looks
the same to me
to be honest with you so that's it
I need to use both sides of the archway
to get the platform to the other side of
the bridge
very nice
thank you
let's get used to the SE floors
honestly yeah everything everything
looks the same
thank you PB J
there we go
experience
foreign
there we go
it wasn't so bad
um what do you guys say
foreign
quite effective
way
oh
there we go
oh good to know
I've got much to learn guys
what that part
you mean the last little riddle
that one was okay it was just the one
before it I couldn't
figure out because the room just looked
the same to me
I wish I could zoom out
foreign
ouch
you know
you can't change field of view
experience
foreign
drink up
ouchy
honest
couldn't break up
spelling
nice
oh I didn't know that
yeah I used Stupify finally
damn new stuff what a relief
I got one stupifying
shouldn't have used the ancient Magic on
the other guys of the waste
another pencil
yoink
foreign
[Music]
what's the max level in this game
40. your ability to transfigure the
world around you is remarkable that must
be higher than that
what is it that's it
my father isn't getting better
seems like it should be higher I don't
think he'll ever recover from
too diagonizing to see those we love
suffer
the trout was years ago but the pain of
losing him is as deep for him now as if
it happened only yesterday
he doesn't need pretty pillars he needs
peace
I could help him professor
which for your father already it's not
enough
I want to take away his pain
it is tempting I know to use this magic
that you're gonna do a video on right I
think more than the physical world
but human emotions I have so many videos
unto itself
even the most well-meaning and competent
witch cannot possibly know the
consequences of irrevocably manipulating
it so I'm to watch as my father's pain
destroys him
it is not your pain to take
You Gotta Have A Beard like that to have
a hat like that and robes to match
honestly every year a student sees
something sillier than I could ever
imagine in their tea leaves
oh miss Morgana welcome back to Hogwarts
Professor it's funny that
it's presumably a powerful
wizard yes ridiculed
sit sit is Adora tell us about your
travels
I was actually hoping that you and the
others might join with my home this
evening
there's my
there's might like to share
with the most deadly spell other than a
valley the others know uh I mean there
are lots of lethal spells bombardo
Maxima would be a bad way to go
transmography and torture
find a way out of it
is there anything in here I should
look around for
what is this thing
what's everyone's favorite spell in this
game
what do you mean Fallen do you mean like
repercussions
unspeakables
um work in the department of mysteries
and the ministry of magic
uh
uh or the wizard police
says can see the future
yeah I'm gonna do a video on the
Bellatrix thing because
we didn't really have a
spell in Canon to properly explain it
before
um so I think
needs to be readdressed
what have we here it's on the it's on
the list I'm a student at Hogwarts sir
and this is Professor Fick professor
Charles Brookwood At Your Service
has someone completed the first trial I
have Professor Brookwood
you look familiar sir I imagine you saw
me in the first Pence of you accessed in
Gringotts what's Imperial like in this
game you found the Portuguese to access
Professor rackham's fault and you decide
how does it work within the locket you
found floating above that picture you
can I did
run them off a cliff or something I
can't identify floating above the last
pensive ah yes you will find a similar
artifact in each trial once you have
them all we will very well
oh really are you able to tell me
interesting before you proceed I would
like to speak with Charles regarding the
uh
goblins
the student has seen traces of a
powerful dark magic they and they met
they also encounter hmm
we shall defer to you in this matter of
course
now then wait Professor the name
Rookwood do you think that there's a
connection to Victor
perhaps but we can't be sure of its
significance if any for now tell me what
you saw in the pensive before the witch
from the last pencil Isadora became a
Hogwarts professor she argued with
Professor is cool I wish we could learn
that contemporary in this hopefully the
next but you know why it's not in this
for now who knows the answer to that
knows
will be honest I have no idea where to
start actually I might know of someone
well it's worth it my study that's it
yeah Ellen got it
uh before you go
Professor have you encountered swirling
traces of magic in the not that I recall
evidence of the Keeper's efforts to
manipulate the pup if I am correct and
the usual thank you sir
foreign
yes and who knows the counter curse
detective sample guys who knows it
[Music]
who can tell me
the name of the counter curse for sectum
sempra anyone
close I should ask Sarah
that's it foxygen vulnera senator
okay guys I think I'm done for the night
uh but I'll be back again tomorrow
tomorrow night
it'll be light again most likely
um also keep an eye out I've got a video
coming out tomorrow at 3 P.M Eastern
Time
totoy that's the right spelling
okay have a good night everyone Thanks
for uh thanks for watching
I'll see you again soon
thanks Sky High
I would like to teach you descendo you
spoke for pulling objects bye bye bye
bye
thank you Alex